هل ميسي لما سافر من باريس على الرياض ما
كان بيعرف انه راح يتعاقب لما يسافر بدون
اذن اداره الفريق وبعد الخساره ثلاثه واحد
من لوريان ويغيب عن التدريبات اعتقد انه
كان بيعرف طيب السؤال هون ليش ميسي سافر
رغم انه كان بيعرف انه راح يتعاقب
بالتاكيد هذا في رساله ربما تكون انه هو
ما عن مؤمن بمشروع الفريق وما عاد مهتم
انه يكمل مع باريس سان جيرمان الموسم
المقبل وبالتالي قد يكون الخيال الامثل هو
الانتقال للهلال ليش لانه الخيار الثالث
وهو الانتقال الى برشلونه يبدو امر شبه
مستحيل بسبب اوراق برشلونه الماليه
المعقده وموضوع استقاله المانيا اعتقد انه
راح ياثر على موضوع التعاقد مع ميسي ايضا
وراح ياثر على استقرار الاداري في الفريق
بخصوص سوق التعاقدات وسوق الانتقالات
الموضوع الاخر او سؤال اخر اللي بدهنه على
طول هو ليش ميسي جايب معه عائلته على
السعوديه هل يعرفهم على المكان اللي راح
يكون في نواصل مقبل ولا انه هو كونه سفير
للسياحه بالسعوديه جاي يروج الاماكن
المناسبه للعائلات مع عائلته